في تحركاتنا لكسب الحديقه الخلفيه او
انتزاعها تشعر واشنطننا ربما انها تاخرت
قمه استثنائيه ليست لجهه انها جمعت خمسين
زعيما ومسؤولا افريقيا بل لكونها الثانيه
التي تعقد بعد قمه اليتيمه تراساها باراك
اوباما في 2014
نعم خطوتنا تعكس استراتيجيه امريكيه جديده
وهي التي اعلنت عنها في اغسطس الماضي
لتوجهها لتتوجها عفوا بقيمه منح فيها
القاره السمراء 55 مليارا اي تقريبا مليار
دولار لكل دوله
تاخرت واشنطن التي تسبقها الصين حتى
بمعرفتك ما تحتاجه افريقيا وسنتطرق لذلك
بالتفصيل بعد قليل 60 مليار دولار خطها
بكينا في قمه 2018 استثمارات ومساعدات
الماليه الحقدتها لتنازلا كريم في 2020
حين تخلات عن 10 مليارات دولار ديون
لافريقيا ومنحتها مليارات اللقاحات بصفه
مجانيه لدعمها في مواجهه الجائحه للمفارقه
ليست كافيه مع عامل الحرب الاوكرانيه الذي
يهدد افريقيا بمجاعه تحذر منها الامم
المتحده كما تبقي القاره وتبقى متعطشه
للمزيد من التنميه مهما كان المالح وكيفما
كانت التقاطعات الامنيه والعسكريه
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه بين القوه الموجوده
ومن هنا دخل لاعب جديد قوي ظاهريا لكنه في
مازقنا يدفعه لاخراج ورقه
انجري باريس
ربما طرب بريطانيا او الحزب المحافظ للقاء
الفرصه الثاني حاليا لتحقيق رؤيه بريطانيا
العالميه المسار الخاص بعد بريزات الذي
سيمنحها الخضره على الاستقلاليه ولو جزئيه
عن اوروبا اقتصاديا سياسيا وامنيا ورؤيه
باتت اكثر الحاحا خاصه وان التقارب
المامول مع واشنطن بما قد يعوض التراجع في
العلاقات مع اوروبا لم يكتمل الولايات
المتحده اعاده النظر بيولوياتها
واهتماماتها الان تحاولوا لندن تاسيس
سياسه خارجيه جديده لها هذا صحيح ولم
تخصها بافريقيا فقط وربما الدول الافريقيه
مهما كانت استراتيجيه لندن تبقى بالنسبه
للقاره مستعمرا سابقا مستغلا للثروات
هو شكل من اشكال اعاده التموضع مهما تعدد
التسمياته في وجه الحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا من جهه وتوسع نفوذ الصين التي
يصفها ريش سوناك بالتحدي النظامي من جهه
ثانيه بريطانيا تريد بناء علاقات مع بلدان
متزايده التاثير معظمها في امريكا
اللاتينيه واسيا وايضا القاره الافريقيه
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني زار خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه كينيا واثيوبيا واعدا
بمزيد من الاستثماراتها فيها تنطلق هذه
الزيارات مما سماها كلافلي البراجماتيه
التطلعيه حيث يرى انا الاستثمار في
البلدان الافريقيه الرئيسيه يوفر فوائد
ضخمه للمملكه المتحده والى جانب الدعم
عقده بريطانيا منذ البراكز اتفاقيات في
شارع حراء مع سبعه عشره دوله افريقيه
قيمتها تفوق 18 مليار جنيه كذلك رئيس جنوب
افريقيا زار بريطانيا الشهر الماضي معلنا
شراك بين البلدين في مجالي الصحه والعلوم
كما تناولت المحادثات التجاره والاستثمار
فيما يبدو انها كلها تاتي محاولات لتعزيز
التعاون بين بريطانيا وشركاه غير تقليديين
خاصه بعد اعلان سوناك نهايه العهد الذهبي
مع الصين